hey Google
can you show me a video of hell but in
live action without pretty stuff and
doubles
[Music]
why are you so crazy
you're crazy
okay while he's looking up images of
hell
I'm actually planning for a really CUNY
trip because today we're about to add
another sticker to our little travel
cooler because we're gonna go to Willow
Beach in Arizona I just found out that
it's only an hour away shout outs to
this IG page called the other Las Vegas
they showcase a lot of like
um other parts of Las Vegas as mama was
talking about
um but they had this beautiful
video of
um them kayaking let me see if I can
find it and when I saw that I was like
oh I have to go here and this is where
we're trying to go to today or is it
there it is look at that
so shout outs to the other Las Vegas
look at that
isn't that beautiful the Colorado River
so the Colorado River is only an hour
away from Vegas which is another thing
that I really really like oh shout outs
to Kiara
um love about Las Vegas is it's very
Central in the southwest so if you're
trying to explore uh Utah Arizona New
Mexico Colorado Arizona did I say
Arizona already it's all very very
convenient it's a really cool hot spot
to hit a bunch of States so we're gonna
be getting a canoe and a kayak so got to
make sure everything stays within weight
limit and we're gonna be on the water
for a long time so we're packing for the
whole day and look at how excited mama
is about Mia's little vest yeah cause
when we took her to the lake yeah she
was swimming for a long time but she
gets tired so we would
the lake was super shallow anyway so she
could swim and then she could stand
eventually but like this is gonna be red
yeah she's gonna be on the boat with us
so we got to keep everything safe we got
a little life vest
there it is Arizona Arizona yeah we just
crossed it right here we just saw the
Hoover Dam so now we're gonna head 13
miles and we'll be at Willow Beach which
is a part of the Colorado River and the
Colorado River I believe runs through
Arizona and connects to Hoover Dam so
it's all like connected which is super
cool
what do you guys think
yeah yeah same
like boring geography class
ES
[Music]
okay so we just got in it's a 10 minute
drive to get to like the lake water area
the Marina Marina excuse me
um but super lucky that we booked a
reservation online because today like
there was a sign that said it's closed
because they're at capacity
um so there's no more parking spaces
Etc
um so if you do plan on coming here I
highly recommend coming early especially
if you're coming in the summertime
because everyone's going to be here I
actually learned from the other Vlog
remember our other Vlog at Lake Mead
yeah what I didn't book a reservation I
was oh we should be able to just get it
just fine that's you everywhere when I'm
like we gotta Reserve everything I know
well like the fun part of camping is to
me is improv like what happens okay so
with that we drove like two hours away
with David he didn't make a reservation
we couldn't stay there we stayed one
night we just stay one night they said
yeah
so this time I learned I booked a
reservation so they allowed Us in but
yeah during the summer time I think all
these beautiful lakes have crazy I mean
like crazy traffic so they do end up
filling up so it will come early you're
literally saying everything I just said
you're so boring what did taika eat what
did Tyga eat let me see your face you
got chocolate over stuff
well way to give the answer away no
that's not what he ate I didn't give
nothing away
you get part of the end this guy is
driving I'm about to open this door and
roll out because this guy is just so
boring please do that do both both of
them thank you baby
all right so we found the marina
and that's the beautiful water over
there
just checked in which if you ever come
here you just come down to the American
flag make a left and that's where you
pick up your paperwork because they'll
give you a ticket to to be able to go
down to the bottom and actually check
out
um with their boats and we have a
soldier with chocolate all over his face
yeah and then you can get one of these
wheelbarrows so it makes it easy because
you could technically only Park here for
one hour
so we're just unloading and then I'm
gonna move the truck and then we can
take all of this stuff
down to the actual dock load the dock we
got two canoes so we could have all
kinds of stuff I think each canoe has
like a 800 pound or 700 pound capacity
so we can bring our picnic on the road
and right now we're switching over to
our water shoes because we learned from
last time that it's just way easier to
get in and out of watercraft walk in the
lake and river because sometimes it's
like Rocky and stuff so you just want
something that won't just fall off and
works in both dry and wet environments
because we were walking around with
Crocs and since they're so loose they
just slip off right away good thing they
float so they come straight to the
surface but it's kind of hard to keep
track of stuff when you're swimming
around and then your Footwear just falls
off well first all right we got the
wheelbarrow ready to go we got Mr
Gilligan ready have a goodbye see you
later we got Ginger who are you from
Gilligan's Island
that's the oldest reference
yeah no it's not just Colors oh look at
how blue the water is
so look at this we get to explore
everywhere around here
this is beautiful oh look at that
oh I can't wait to get in are you
excited Mama yeah
look at that little guy all the way down
there main difference that's nothing at
all like riding a bike okay perfect but
you need like it's easy like riding a
bike oh sure
no it's really not too difficult though
gotta take a little T at the top put
your hand right off the top of the tee
put your other hand about halfway down
when you paddle you're using both hands
so push at the top and then pull at the
bottom at the same time okay and then
just like canoeing kayaking uh you're
gonna go the opposite direction so pedal
on your left to go right right to go
left gotcha uh my main tip is just sit
straight up do not lean over you know
don't you know we have clear water don't
look at the fish I'd say tip over okay
as long as you sit straight up you'll be
perfectly fine okay uh right now we're
standing in Arizona
that mountain over there is Nevada oh
it's gonna wanna go straight across that
mountain over there because the current
squeaker over there and you'll be
protected from the wind got it
so we're we'll follow the crowd pretty
much yeah it's about a mile and a half
up you guys are going to the cave right
oh no we're just exploring but yeah sure
where should we go uh there is the
emerald cave about a mile and a half up
it's gonna take you about 45 minutes to
an hour to get there and probably like
you're gonna be in line for an hour or
two so we're probably not going to go to
the cave yeah
you got beautiful views you got beaches
on both sides of the river a bunch of
places to stop just enjoy yourselves
awesome thank you so much okay we're
gonna go this way yeah careful monkey
there you go good job no wonder they
make handles on that thing
okay
you feel safe feel stable
[Music]
okay see you later Mama bye bye
foreign
happening over there bumping music out
of his jet ski and then we got mama and
Mia over there
lagging behind me and her CUNY life vest
note to self we for sure need to get a
speed though next time because I'll move
way faster I think canoes are made for
two people so had we been able to put
two people in this canoe we could row
away faster but they have a three
heartbeat limit meaning
um it would only have to be me taika and
Gio and nomia or mijio and uh Mia and
otaka so we had to get two canoes
because of the three heartbeat limit so
now we know
there's mama
and Mia how is it rolling with the CUNY
doggy
oh really yeah just wants to jump in the
water yeah yeah stay right there I'm
gonna take a picture of you all right
look how clear this water is look at
that
you see the Rocks underneath
it's still green it's still green you're
right so we're floating right next to a
bunch of rocks right now so there's no
beach to park taika's getting impatient
he wants to swim me too it's hot I can't
wait to jump in the water I'm actually
hungry because we got yummy food in here
so I gotta keep paddling we got Mama
right behind us
and I better start pounding before I
crash into the Rocks right there yeah
about like you make like lunch yeah it's
gonna cook our lunch huh
all right so we found the first Beach
that we can
to bank our canoes water's pretty clear
and we had our canoes over here
yeah it's not like a Big Sandy Beach but
it's private which is good we saw
another Beach over there but someone had
like three little dogs so we wanted to
make sure that we're away from them so
that we can just have our CUNY little
privacy
so now I can set up a little picnic
and eat something yummy and I know you
want to go swimming right
you can go swimming now if you want come
here okay
all right time to set up for lunch I got
my sandwich Mama made a bunch of
sandwiches those look delicious I think
that's the Cheesecake Factory bread huh
yeah really cold
there are
literally a ton of bugs because you can
tell this place is like super
uninhabited so we see spiders that are
like this big okay let's just not
talking about all kinds of bugs all over
the place just swarming
and Mama's tripping out well yeah I'm
not sitting anywhere here
Mia's having a blast so we kept the life
vest on her even though we know she can
swim just in case she just starts
drifting away then we feel safe that
like she'll just be drifted in the
middle over there by herself
you want to sit on the boat and eat no
there's a lot of spiders inside the boat
yes there's one right there oh my God
look at that thing
all right
oh my God all right so I saw the mother
Loda spiders and Mama started to trip it
but you see that bush there's literally
like spiders every five inches
the spiders up there there's a spider
web up there spiders all of all of these
guys all of these guys are about like
this big
at the king one
why
is gnarly they're not gonna do anything
they're just hanging out
nope they're literally not gonna do
anything nope
look this guy's a mess
you're saying that as you're going away
see see look you're you're a strong
tough man huh yep
look how big these mofos are there are a
ton look at that
there's a ton of them
they're all just chilling
spiders literally off every Bush there's
like a billion of them that one's moving
around there's a giant web right there
holy moly that's the motherload
[Music]
you don't have to jump in huh okay here
we go
see you later sail the seven seas
good
so we gotta find another spot because
Mama's freaking out over the spiders so
we gotta find some runs where we can
relax because both me and taika still
want to swim but you should have seen
Mama Bear she was so cute she's standing
on this pile of rocks right here holding
like clutching onto her stuff like oh my
God oh my God oh my God oh my God
so oh my God the water feels so good and
we just have to keep moving around
[Music]
all right so we've been rowing for a
while looking for a beach and I think I
just found one I see a patch of dirt
over there this is brown which means
there's open space
yes we're over there because over here
if you look closely all the bushes have
a bunch of like white stuff on it which
means it's full of spiders so even when
I found like little mini beaches like
that tree right there is full of spider
webs so Mama over there is gonna freak
out for sure
but over here I think I found a beach
hey Mama I found a beach you see the all
the patches of sand over there
okay it's like all beige
and look at me and me is so CUNY
dude there's a little spider you're
gonna freak out yeah you're gonna freak
out
no look at that tree it's full of spider
webs
why are you going there
this trip is such a disaster
all right guys
we made it just beached our canoes we
came all the way from like
the mouth of that Cliff right there we
paddled all the way over here it
actually looks way farther like it looks
like it would take I don't know a couple
hours but it took only like 20 30
minutes to be honest
so we're here
yeah this guy can't wait to swim me too
do you feel safe and happy here yes yes
okay good
there's no spiders oh my God what's that
far away for me that one was like right
in here I could hear them talking to
each other oh it gets better yeah
whatever yeah everyone's swimming oh
it's cool it's cold as refreshing yeah
oh it's cold is it cold cold
because what Justice does not prefer
okay here I come here it comes
oh yeah
[Music]
go in the water
there goes papa there's Mia there's Papa
where are you
[Music]
there he goes Mia come
yeah
where is he
there he is here
there
she's like forget it
you're done check out couch
Mia is right there wet fur
not to be confused with taika is
sleeping
and taika is so exhausted this dude had
a scrimmage this morning for his
um basketball team
and then he did everything you guys just
saw so he is spent and I couldn't be
happier so it is an hour drive from
where we live because we did enter Utah
as bar mentioned uh sorry where the hell
am I Arizona
and rain no one knows yep see you
see I called it as soon as he was
missing
um so yeah it is an hour drive which is
perfect because then it gives time for
Tyga to sleep remember if you want your
kids to sleep I don't know if you're
going to be in our situation where
um sleeping yeah sleeping triggers your
child's seizures but if you are I say
um bring a bed sheet because this
situation was covered with me as fur and
I just can't have my boy in that
blanket and then a pillow ironically
enough that pillow came from Grandma's
bed we're supposed to give that back to
Grandma but my grandma my mom AKA his
grandma is so sweet that she's like take
it with you so you can think of me and
always and I'm pretty sure she's missing
it from her bed so she probably has like
three pillows instead of four she's
probably like so she has slight OCD so I
bet it drives her crazy because she's
like oh there's only three pillows there
should be four so I need to give this
pillow back but
long story not that long yes that's what
we pack for him
I know I wish it was my size I would
totally joined too but this was a really
fun trip I learned something about
myself today
what I learned is I don't want to do any
more goddamn work like I'm over
roughing camping like I'm not gonna
sleep on the floor anymore I'm over this
kayak where I have to
row it myself like I'm highly
capable of doing it but just because I
can do it doesn't mean I want to I'm too
old I need a motor in the back
and some margaritas that's what the
I'm saying
we couldn't even hang out together like
I was like so far behind you guys it was
you tuning us to and Mia wouldn't leave
the in between my legs so like
my boat was constantly crooked I
couldn't even roast I kept like knocking
her in the head and I'm like I'm so
sorry Mia but yeah I'm just too old for
this like I just want to relax and
and be taken care of like the princess I
wish I was
I like to see you freak out with the
spiders though why I'm never that
vulnerable huh no it's just cute just
just turned into like a fight girl girl
I never do that I know it's rare it's
rare it's rare that I become a girl and
then I forget that
it's like a little
little little
what hello girl audience
you guys saw that that was great
that's the spider that bit
Peter Parker I hope you know
those things are massive that
was disgusting like they had like
writing on their belly
and then taika kept playing with one or
two spiders in your kayak right
yeah because well we switch kayak or
canoes because you saw a bunch of them
climb into your Canadians
oh my God I look that cute yeah and then
so we're like well I just switched in so
when we switched but me and talk to
saddle there's a bunch of them are
running around and so while I was really
tackled I tried to play with them had a
bunch of them on his hand running around
well I'm happy I'm happy because I want
him to just do his and not get scared of
I don't want him to carry my pussiness
yeah so I'll let him carry his own
pussiness and I'm glad that spiders
isn't one of them
um so yeah that's what I learned about
myself so the next trip we're definitely
getting something with a motor
um I would definitely come back another
thing I got bit by a wasp I
think
like a lot of wildlife here if it was
yeah who would have thought Wildlife
would have Wildlife or yeah but yeah
like I just felt something bite me
really hard on my arm and I smacked it
because just instincts
um so I smacked it and I ended up
smacking something really big but it was
behind my arm so I didn't get to see
what insect or animal it actually was so
I'm assuming it's a wasp because I did
see some of those flying around and that
was kind of the biggest thing I saw
outside of dragonflies but dragonflies
don't
bite
so I'm assuming it was a wasp but it
hurt it is a little bit swollen
um I did look it up and it's nothing to
really
be concerned about unless you have like
a crazy reaction which you can have like
an anaphylactic
like or like reaction which you'd be
like spazzing out or whatever but
um even the area in which the WASP that
I think bit me it is swollen it was
burning at first and that was maybe like
an hour ago now it feels better and I
feel like the swelling is going down so
I think my body's just kind of handling
it
um
yeah I was wearing perfume that I didn't
realize
I had because I put it on in the morning
just didn't even think put it on the
morning and then I thought I just I
couldn't smell it anymore so I think
um that's probably what was attracting
these like mosquitoes and whatever other
bugs were around that just kept kind of
sticking on me
so I would recommend bringing
what is it called bug repellent
what else would I bring
I think that's it everything else was
pretty good we had water shoes which was
a lifesaver because everything was
really Rocky the water was super clear
which was really really convenient and
beautiful it was super cold but
it felt like a cold plunge so I would
get in
um
for a little bit and then I would get
back out but it was so hot outside that
I would probably stay out for like maybe
five ten minutes and then I'd go back in
and I just kept doing that back and
forth so it was super relaxing everyone
like the community around there is
really really sweet everyone talks to
you it's like
um common courtesy to just say what's up
you know they're like hey how are you
doing and I'm like we're just passing
each other up but hey I'm good how are
you
um so it was good I highly do recommend
it it's a lot of family fun I don't know
how much the chi are kayaks were
canoes my bad
um I think they're like two
I don't know it was that expensive yeah
so originally I was like 200 bucks
nothing dude by my own but I looked it
up and I think our own because it would
have been 300 but then I might as well
but then you think about oh well you
have to get life jackets and all that so
the canoe comes with all of that you
know it comes with like the life jacket
and it also comes with like the giving
profit back to the conservation of the
areas oh okay okay it's finally gotta
give it all to them fine I was gonna say
very affordable but never mind
um but it was worth it I I another
reason why I want to get something with
the motor outside of me being old as
and not wanting to do work but more
importantly is I want to go further down
the Colorado River yeah the Colorado
River to really see what's down there I
think it took us like about an hour to
40 or 40 minutes to an hour to get to
where we were which really wasn't deep
at all I want to see it was maybe like a
mile in I would love to like cruise down
the Colorado River to see what's going
on yeah there's another place that
everyone was talking about called
Emerald cave yeah
take caves and it's like shimmering and
it's all green in there so
we'll be back with friends
and we added another
sticker to the collection and that one's
CUNY because that's exactly what we did
which is row about
so now we got all of these we gotta fill
up that one more space right there
and then we start going the on the sides
CUNY